welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we're hosting webinars
every Tuesday my name is Colin Frierson
and today we're gonna be talking about G
suite security we're gonna look at MDM
Enterprise security and protection and
more you can ask questions any time on
the platform and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them with that let's
get started
so one of the things we know is it's
becoming increasingly difficult for IT
to manage and protect assets at scale
the average IT organizations has
thousands of services they're trying to
manage both on Premanand cloud and a
high percentage of data breaches are
caused by employees due to a lack of
internal controls meaning it's very
difficult to govern when employees have
access to data and when they don't and
where that data goes we're also seeing
that patchwork systems makes you know
the system as a whole much more
vulnerable so meaning you're going to
have varying operating systems on Prem
varying patch levels on those systems
and those varying patch levels can be
exploited by documents by malicious code
that are often delivered by email and
the cost of these breaches is going up
the number of breaches we've seen is
actually increasing and data breaches
can be catastrophic
so you know we understand that's really
well at Google and we've been designing
our products to try to address these
concerns some of the things we've
noticed you know ninety percent plus of
phishing attacks start with email
similarly with malware we see that you
know 66% or maybe even a little more of
malware is actually delivered via email
or an attachment via email so it's
really important we defend that from the
beginning and again very high percentage
of employee of reported breaches are
caused by either employees not
understanding where the proper
boundaries are being extorted or by an
external threat and data exfiltration is
expense
we're seeing a super-high increase in
the losses from ransomware over the last
couple years so at Google we really
believe that you know being in that
cloud native can really help you defend
against these types of modern threats
there's some amazing capabilities you
know that work across the platform
whether you're in the Google Drive
ecosystem directly or in Gmail or using
Chrome Enterprise our robust global
infrastructure is designed to always be
up-to-date so no one is ever running an
old version of Gmail
we deploy security patches to Chrome on
a very regular basis and the
infrastructure is global so that we
minimize the amount of time your traffic
is actually on the web and we bring it
in to Google as fast as possible so as
we're building products inside of G
suite we think about it in a couple of
different buckets proactive intelligent
compliant and simple so what I'm gonna
do today is kind of take you through
each of these areas of work inside of G
Suites and then you know please feel
free to ask questions and we can dive
into any any area that we need to a
little bit more proactive I think is one
of the most important ones you know
again you know we see a ton of spam and
phishing campaigns that come directly in
from email so being defensive at email
is really important and you know Gmail
is very effective at stopping spam and
malware we have three nines here which
is really really impressive and this is
hard to do the the 99.9% the way we're
able to achieve that is actually through
machine learning I'm gonna talk a little
bit more about this in a bit but this is
how we're able to classify you know spam
and malware not just based on signature
or by sender reputation we have a lot of
signals that were able to use and we
also classify at multiple points during
message delivery a couple of other
interesting things we're doing with
machine learning these are some new
stats we actually just published these a
couple weeks ago every minute we're at
10 million spam messages prevented from
reaching a gmail inbox okay
10 million per minute
right this is a huge number and again
like this is based on that machine
learning with 99.9% accuracy rates over
half a million pages indexed and scan
for harmful software so this is using
the Google search engine we're actually
looking for malicious sites sites that
host malware you know links that might
be in your email that would direct you
to a page that would do something
harmful 7-thousand deceitful urls
browser extensions that may carry
viruses unwanted content phishing
attempts again we're detecting 7,000 new
ones per minute and we're also scanning
6,000 instances of software that could
be malicious to Chrome so these are you
know binaries that are hosted and when
you download them chrome would warn you
that this binary may harm your computer
are you sure you want to keep it and
every minute to new phishing sites and
one new to phishing sites and one
malware site are found and labeled so
they're added to the chrome Safe
Browsing database this is only possible
with Google search like the search
engine and machine learning really make
this possible
and talking more about about the email
accuracy you know there's a lot of
vendors in this space that do you know
email detection what we really think
sets us apart is the machine learning
that is individualized so meaning not
only are we able to detect ransomware
detect you know messages they will morph
so we'll see these messages try to beat
signature detection they'll send
millions of emails and try to look to
see which ones are the most effective
but we're also able to look for things
you know also that are in the Safe
Browsing database so when you attach a
link you know Google will look at where
the link goes and then if it's sending
you to a malicious page will stop you
from getting there will even strip the
link out and also this is doesn't just
apply to inbound messages this applies
to outbound as well so we actually will
look for sensitive information that you
as an adjudicator can configure with our
data loss prevention engine and then
detect if content that is leaving the
organization meets compliance rules so
you can say look if you're if you're
sending emails with a lot of swear words
in them I could block that if you're
sending emails with you know sensitive
information like credit card numbers
names addresses
once it meets a certain threshold you
can warn blocker change routing rules
the the email layers of Defense's are
really cool and there's a lot of them so
for example we're doing a lot of checks
pre delivery and this is this is partly
how we get to that 99.9 percent as a
message comes in to Gmail we look not
only for rule-based matching so did the
sender you know did it come from a
sender with a poor reputation we also
are able to even open any attachments in
a virtual machine and and essentially
see what they did to the machine so
we'll dump the memory we'll look at the
disk and determine really quickly
usually inside of four minutes if that
binary is malicious this is really how
we're looking for zero days and then of
course we'll use multiple antivirus
engines to look for you know known
signatures you know if there's you know
a zip file with contents in it will open
it will extract it all and we'll see
what's in there we also look again on
message open so we rerun a lot of these
checks on message open we know that you
know email is happening in real time so
even post delivery we can check to see
you know did did the links in this site
you know match a new Safe Browsing data
entry you know we can display warning
banners inside of Gmail and you know
going even further when you open an
attachment if you're opening it in the
Gmail web UI that's actually a sandbox
where we're actually opening the
attachment so it's really difficult for
a traditional you know like macros or
PDF exploits for those to execute inside
the chrome sandbox inside of Gmail again
looking at Safe Browsing links on link
click so before you click on anything
we're gonna check for the Safe Browsing
database about where you're about to be
headed we're also sending things like
reply so if someone is impersonating
your domain so they've spun up a domain
that's very you know similar to yours
they have a character to that's
different and they're asking for
information Google will automatically
warren a user that hey you're about to
send information that's sensitive
outside the domain are you sure you want
to do that again also doing data loss
prevention checks when you're doing an
oauth grant so if someone's trying to
ask you to click on a link that
authorizes a third party application to
your G suite applications we can
actually look at DLP before we send any
information to that third party finally
some of the best ones are password
verification and password reset so we'll
do 2-step verification when we see
suspicious you know login attempts and
we can also challenge when someone's
sending you like password reset emails
we'll make sure those are really coming
from from secure sources I think it's
also important to acknowledge that we
can interlock a lot of these protections
with Chrome OS Chrome OS is is one of
the most secure computing platforms on
the market today and we're not only
combining all of those capabilities that
we just talked about but we're combining
it with a secure foundation for the
client so meaning the device the
firmware the OS are all designed with
security in mind so a couple examples
here the first one is every Chromebook
on the market is fully encrypted that's
by design
like we don't offer there isn't a
Chromebook on the market today you can
find that isn't it fully encrypted and
actually we're encrypting the the user
space the OS itself is actually
open-source so there's no need to
encrypt that the firmware is also
designed to have secure boot so meaning
anytime Chrome OS every time Chrome OS
boots we actually check to make sure
that the OS is intact with firmware and
if something's wrong you'll you'll
rarely see that screen that says hey
something's wrong you need to insert a
USB Drive and you know reimage your
Chromebook and again the OS platform is
managed by Google so we're delivering
security updates every six weeks or if
you want to opt in to the beta or a dev
channels you can get updates even faster
but again like there's you won't find
Chromebooks that are running really old
versions of Chrome we automatically push
these updates and we we can really stay
ahead of the curve with patching all
right with that let's let's talk about
intelligence so today we actually have
three billion devices that are checked
with Safe Browsing technology and we're
you know again scanning the entire
internet for harmful software and for
malicious sites and we want to make all
of this data available so one of the
tools we just launched in G suite is
called Security Center Security Center
is a place where administrators can go
to look for you know data on
everything that would be relevant to
someone who's a security professional so
how many phishing emails are am I
getting in my domain is it turning up or
turning down you know how many of them
are blocked how many of them are blocked
retroactively Lee you know how many
links am I getting that contain malware
how many attachments contain malware and
then even data on how the users are
behaving you know how many ooofff links
that I you know as a user creating what
applications have they authorized to see
data inside their domain and you can
even retroactively go back and revoke
finally in Security Center I think one
of the coolest features is this is an
assistant a security assistant that we
have so it actually provides
recommendations and best practices for
security in the domain and you can see
you know recommendations like hey if you
have your super admins and they don't
have to factor authentication turned on
you should turn that on and you can you
can accept those recommendations or you
can say yeah I accept the risk so it's
it's live so it will interact with you
as you go through it really important
tool I think to take a look at the
second one is data loss prevention so
this tool has been around in Gmail for a
while we launched it in Drive earlier or
late last year so DLP and drive will
actually let you look for sensitive
content across your entire organization
so meaning when you're looking for
things like you know names credit card
numbers sensitive data that would likely
be the source of a breach you can apply
rules programmatically to that data so
what that means is you can allow users
to share you know so long as the content
isn't filled with names or credit card
numbers or social security numbers we
can hold all that on Google platform by
the way we have lots of compliance
certifications showing that we can do
that but you want to make sure that you
users are still behaving in a way that's
you know governed by the security policy
this is actually a tool that was built
by Google you know for itself we
actually built this as part of a log
sanitization engine so it's trained with
machine learning it runs at scale and
operates actually in a very similar way
that our Gmail scanning works every time
someone makes an edit DLP reruns
reevaluate the rules so it works on live
documents and of course it works even
with non Google native objects you know
like Word documents PDF
images things like that great so with
that let's let's talk briefly about
compliance so at Google we have a we
have a pretty simple philosophy when it
comes to compliance and that is we
should find the strongest technical
certifications and at cessations we can
find globally and and adhere to those
standards so this has been a huge body
of work for Google and we've been
looking at things like the ISO series
27001 is you know your standard cloud
security attestation 27-17 is the the
list of all those technical controls and
ISO 27:18 is actually the cloud privacy
standard so it makes sure that the data
that you put inside of G suite is
private from both a multi-tenancy
perspective it's private from the house
like which would be Google and private
from any third parties Google does
business with so it's a really strong
standard really happy we got that a
couple years ago we also offer stock
reports so if you need an SSA e reports
or a type 2 report we can definitely
provide that and G suite is FedRAMP
certified at the moderate level so this
has also been around for a while but
again it attests to this strength of the
controls that we have in place we're
also you know gearing towards regulatory
compliance so things like you know the
u.s. it's healthcare with HIPAA so we
want to make sure that you know if
you're storing health related
information in G suite we can protect
that data adequately also similarly with
GD P R and the EU so we want to make
sure that even you know the data in G
suite is held to the highest privacy
standards and the EU is really leading
on this it's worth mentioning we offer
this to all of our customers we don't
differentiate between the editions so
regardless of what G suite Edition
you're in we're gonna offer these to you
no matter where you are a couple of the
commitments you know there's never any
ads in G suite Google does not collect
your data we don't scan it for
advertising we don't create our key o
types we don't do any of that in G
Suites and you don't have to believe me
in this it's in our Terms of Service for
G Suites so you can look at the contract
it's very goods very clear you own the
data this is also in the contract Google
myths that we have no intellectual
property rights on any of the data you
put in gee sweet it's a hundred percent
yours and you're also responsible for
the content and your apps are always
available we offer a really high SLA we
also have public dashboarding to show we
know the status of our applications this
this SLA includes no time for
maintenance so we're always going to be
at three nines you know we do
maintenance kind of all the time we do
patching all the time so we're always
going to be on the latest version and
we're never gonna take you down for you
know a maintenance window you know it's
some horrible time in the night
we're with Angie sweet is global there's
it's it's always daytime and working
somewhere we also really commit to
control this is really important and you
know that this this to me means two
things one thing is you can always take
your data out of Google if you need to
we don't want you to feel like you're
trapped here so if you've been using
Google Docs or Google slides you can
always export that in industry formats
or open formats and you can also delete
your data so if you tell Google hey I
want to delete all of this data we're
contractually committed to to deleting
that for you and you know processing
that command and again we have these
commitments in contract you can read
more about them in the Terms of Service
or on the data processing amendment last
one is simple you know all these
security controls are great the
philosophy here is if if they're not
simple and it's not very easy for users
to use it typically that's how
workarounds get created and problems
occur so the first one is around the
administration side and the the
administrator tools that are in G Suites
central admin panel are really easy to
use and straightforward I use the search
panel a lot the search panel is really
helpful and we even support natural
language query in the search bar so if
you type password resets you know we'll
understand what that means and we'll
direct you to the right place
we also include tools in here for chrome
management so if you need to administer
Chrome devices whether those are signed
in chrome devices or Chrome OS devices
we can manage those from here we include
our mobile device management in here so
you can manage iOS and Android devices
and we also support information rights
management through this console so you
can determine rules for you know when
content has a certain requirement you
or is that constant allowed to be taken
offline taken out of the domain etc
really powerful
there's also controls for Team drives in
here one of the new things we launched
recently whispered is called protected
team drives which will let you actually
define rules about content in a drive so
that content would you know no matter
what can't be taken offline can't be
taken you know out of the domain you can
even restrict copy and print it's really
powerful our our mobile device
management and cloud identity is also
becoming really popular so we have a ton
of devices now that are under management
and we've actually recently simplified
how much weight we have on the device in
order to put mobile device management on
there so we're calling this like MDM
lights because we don't need an agent
anymore to enforce basic policies things
like encryption and pass codes and we
also still support of course you know
you can push a full agent and have even
more control this is actually on by
default now for new domains which is
really exciting you know we definitely
wanna make sure administrators have
control when users are accessing their
data from a mobile device whether it's
Android or iOS finally I want to spend a
little bit of time on security keys
because this has been key to even
Google's corporate strategy you know
we're we of course eat our own dog food
so we we use G suite tools and Gmail
services just like you know all of our
customers and security keys are
paramount to our strategy for preventing
phishing attacks and preventing account
hijacking remember one of the stats I
quoted earlier was you know over 70% of
phishing campaigns you know start with
an e mail security keys are another
layer of defense for us there so suppose
a phishing email gets through and an
employee clicks on the link the bar we
set with security keys was we want to
build a credential that's so strong that
it's nearly impossible for a bad actor
to steal it okay security keys are how
Google has accomplished that since we
deployed security keys we've had no we
had no reported or detected G suite
account hijackings post-deployment so
that means an employee who has a
security key you know there have been
lots of attempts to steal their
credential
none have been successful that we've
detected or have been reported so
security keys work by actually doing
something very different than
traditional authentication traditional
authentication requires you to
demonstrate to the server that you are
who you say you are what's fundamentally
different about security keys is
security keys require that the server
demonstrate to the client that it's
trustworthy so now we're doing
bi-directional authentication okay so
when you're authenticating with a
security key
you know the server actually
demonstrates to the client that it
really is who it says it is you're
really in a TLS connection with the with
the server there's not a man in the
middle there's not a bad actor phishing
page and that that credential that you
send can't be replayed or reused we have
a great white paper on this if you want
to know more we can I can tell you like
about our experience with security keys
which is a public white paper or you can
learn more about u2f from the phyto
alliance so all that being said we
really believe that you know our
strengths is better together you know
combining the strengths of G suite with
chrome and Android and even G CP is
really gonna help you build a security
framework that is extended beyond the
traditional perimeter you know as
employees become more mobile as
identities really start to span outside
of the traditional perimeter we think
we're building you know the the most
powerfully secure cloud platform you can
adopt out there so tying it all together
we want default on mobile device
management so we want to be able to say
like yep users who are signing in and
accessing Google data from mobile device
managed services are going to be you
know following basic rules like as my
device encrypted you know do I have a
passcode on my lock screen things like
that
advanced anti-phishing capabilities so
again this is when we're we're using
Chrome any link we click on any email
that we get any attachments that's
delivered to our mailbox is going to be
scanned we're gonna be looking for bad
behavior and blocking that by the end
user by default deploying security keys
to the organization so we're doing the
strongest 2fa possible and we're making
sure that users who are coming in really
are who they say they are and they're
authenticating to the
servers and not to hijack der malicious
place using the security console ng
sweets and DLP to make sure the rules of
the organization are followed and
content is where it belongs and not
being shared will you know either
accidentally or maliciously and then
finally using a tool like Google vault
to assure legal compliance with all of
the the data that you're putting in G
suite so you can support things like
e-discovery with that I definitely want
to thank everyone stay tuned for a live
Q&A and we will be back in less than a
minute
you
all right we're back with questions so a
couple questions from the audience do I
need a separate security key for each
account I log into this is a great
question
so security keys the relationship
between keys and accounts is actually
many to many so for any particular
Google account you can actually register
a very large number of security keys
with that account so you don't have to
have just one in case you lose it and
that key can actually be used to unlock
many accounts so you know in my case
like you know my one security key will
unlock you know my corporate account my
personal gmail comm accounts as well as
a bunch of other demo accounts and it
even works for other third party sites
you know sites like github Facebook
Dropbox they all support security keys
natively so you don't need to get a
separate key for each service and you
can have multiple keys for your services
so you don't have to worry about losing
your one key does Google and crypt data
at rest yes we do Google actually
encrypts everything by default with no
action required by the administrator we
actually have a great white paper on
this that talks about how we encrypt
data so if you want to learn more you
know search for gee suite data
encryption and we'll tell you how we
encrypt you know data both in transit
and at rest the great thing is you can't
turn this off so it's always going to be
on ng Suites really fast so it's it's a
great great feature of the platform
how does Google vaults and DLP work with
the new Gmail UI confidential mode so
vault and DLP functionality don't change
so DLP scans run on send or receive so
DLP runs anytime you're sending or
receiving a message so even if you're in
confidential mode we will still run DLP
checks and Google vaults works the same
way we will still vault in archive
messages you know regardless of whether
using confidential or not our DLP and
security center available for all G
suite for business or only enterprise
this is a good question
I'm always we're always moving the
edition things I think security center
and DLP are in enterprise for sure I'm
gonna have to check on whether they're
in the business here or not I don't
remember I think like for some customers
that were grandfathered on business
before we launched Enterprise probably
have access to some of these features
I'm not an expert on skews I apologize
does drive DLP scan current fires or
only ones that have subsequently been
uploaded or created Drive DLP scans
everything so when you first launch a
drive DLP rule will actually scan
everything in the organization so if you
set a policy if it's your first policy
you'll see a pop-up that says it may
take up to 24 hours for this rule to
take effect but that's because we're
scanning all of the shares inside the
organization so we're looking across you
know any existing shares and again like
once the rule is enacted we're looking
on every edit so if I have a bunch of
confident for confidential information
and I'm sharing a document with someone
and I paste all that information into
the document DLP will run as part of
that and then subsequently change my
sharing settings as a result of that so
even if I'm gonna live documents and I
typing as soon as my the keystrokes like
I type create a social security number
or whatever the DLP rule will detect it
will block and change that sharing
setting so it works on everything all
right is that all the questions we have
yep okay well thanks so much for
watching tune in next Tuesday for
another edition of cloud on air
you